using C++ lambdas this video is roughly
based on David Kira's document which is
available online I've coded up all the
examples and elaborated them some and
I'm going to walk through the code and
explain lambdas this is good enough for
complete beginners you should know a
little C++ this might be just beyond
beginner so we're gonna get right into
it how do you use Lambeth lambdas by the
end of this video you should have a
really good understanding of them and
how to use them I'm going to go through
this as quickly as I possibly can and
let's go
so first we made a main.cpp we're gonna
use iostream list algorithm as commented
here so I have a rhythm when you need
four for each we're going to start with
a rather normal way of printing a list
of integers
by the way all this code will be
available on the link in the description
on the github for this channel which I
just opened today so congrats on see in
the beginning of something normal way of
printing your list of integers we just
define a function here that takes an
integer and it outputs it with some
codes in between and then we of course
do our main and make a list of integers
and then we go through the for each from
beginning to end of that end list and
pass in this function print it and this
would work as expected I'm a make file
that's set up to pile and run this with
make run as you can see it prints right
down the line as expected
there's the makefile in case you're
wondering wondering nothing too special
you just type make it compiles the main
dotto
if you type make run it compiles the
main dotto and then runs our executable
right away that's pretty much all this
make file does so I will show you our
directory here we've got the executable
that make file made domain and just a
little more pre-emptive stuff we are on
Windows and we're using cygwin so we're
emulating a Linux environment this
should work the same on any OS as it's
just part of the c++ standard okay so
that's a standard way of printing
integers without a lambda now what a
lambda is is basically an in-place
function its comment out t these go to
the second example this is the exact
same thing except you can see there's no
function defined there's no void print
int instead you go ahead and make a new
line here so it's obvious we're using
the for each function from algorithm and
going from the beginning of this integer
list to the end and this is our lambda
function that prints it out we start out
a lambo know with brackets and then
and we pass in any variables and then
here's all this stuff that our function
does and you'll see if I run this it
will recompile and I'll put the exact
same thing that's the previous one you
might notice that this is less lines of
code well at least when you combine it
up like this okay let's keep moving down
the line I'll show you more examples and
more cool stuff you can do but by the
end of this we should know pretty much
everything you can do with C++ standard
11 with lambdas okay here's another in
this one we're showing you how to call
it right away so if you just declare a
lambda in place there it is you can call
it right after it by parenthesis and a
variable to pass in
oh and as you can see if we run this
oops I got to save this first save
we get the answer 42 from this
see out
so that is passing a value okay then you
can also store your lambda as a variable
using auto here's an example of that we
assign this lambda same one as the
previous two a Auto variable name
function one then we can call it later
and pass in a variable make sure we save
yeah we saved we're gonna do a run
you see we still get 42 from this you
could in theory call this as many times
you want with different numbers if you
want oh I didn't save
just does it twice there since I have a
twice Monroe screw that
you can also call lambda that returns
nothing that returns void
this is what we've been using so far
basically if there is no return
statement anywhere in its definition it
is returning void and that just prints
out something nothing to return but once
we've done before notably haven't had
anything to return either and have just
been returning void
lamb does figure out the return type by
the return in the function definition
here's an example starts out the same
takes in two integers for this function
and it returns
a boolean because it's a comparison it's
saying is I divided by 2 equal to J or
in other words is J half of I and then
we call it with 24 and 12 which do you
think will happen it will return a
boolean of true
let's go to the next one
this is an example of lambdas have more
than one return statement it or if a
type conversion is needed okay this is I
should clarify that you find return
because of having more than one return
statement okay lambdas languishes no
good okay
so you can define a return type by this
little arrow thing before the function
definition it automatically does a
conversion or whatever else you needed
to do if there are multiple return
statements in your definition this will
be needed for example
this here is a lambda that hasn't if
else if and else separated and out to
more than one line so you can see there
we go
close enough and of course we're calling
it right away
so we're doing it within a CL or making
this lambda lambda goes all the way to
there so this one could return multiple
types well they're all point have it
times point something but there's just
different cases of returning different
calculations of X&Y and I threw a point
two in there just for sample so this
first one passes in a four and A three
the second one returns a float and
passes in a four out of three
I changed the numbers slightly they're
in that one this one returns a double
and change the calculation slightly
there that one but otherwise the same
and the last one returns an integer but
it notably takes in two doubles and
we're passing in different numbers so we
should get our four outputs for those
here oh let me make sure I save first
that way it actually compiles the new
version and there is the four outputs
has to be expected
typecasted in all
so that's typecasting arrow our return
type
lamb does have this powerful feature of
capturing local variables you capture
them in those opening square brackets
for example here there is a local double
X and why I would sign them seemingly
random values this says that the lambda
has a copy of them note that it is a
copy of them in this case so we can see
out their values or we should be able to
in this lambda this lambda is split up
to multiple lines but you could do it in
one line of course you can always do
these in one line but whatever is most
readable for your case let's see here
and of course this calls it right away
we have an error oh I didn't save make
run there we go and we get the values
that were passed in or captured rather
as the local variables okay variables
can capture our copy of the original
amount of reference this is the same as
before
this is just a deeper example oops
that they are not copies when this
function that is a lambda is created
it's it's taking a copy of X so X is 42
at that time we call it right away
we should get 42 then we go through this
list where we increment X X is here does
that increase the value in function one
okay what about when we're all done is
this value of x gonna be the same or
different as you can see it is indeed a
copy and this incrementer is
incrementing the outside one not the one
that the lambda has a function of as a
copy of so once we're outside of all of
that we see that the increment has
actually been working just on the
outside one
variable captures our copy of the
original not a reference I already said
that
this is a reference example I believe
where is this the same thing twice
I might have just accidentally put the
same thing in here twice oops
okay this is an example of passing the
variable as a reference this is very
powerful as it's just a pointer it does
not make a copy what do you think will
happen in this one everything is exactly
the same as the last one except that
it's now a reference save this and make
run
as you can see it does actually
increment since it is now a reference
one of the things you can do if you have
a reference is you can have your lambda
change it you could have it modify that
reference capture here's an example of
that as you can see there's no more
increment in this for loop it is now
within the function so the function is
actually taking it and handling all the
business and it still looks the same but
it is done in a different way
that's how you can modify things on the
fly
and this is just an example of doing the
same thing except without saving it has
an auto function first instead just
within your for loop you put your lambda
in there and your little parentheses at
the end to call the right way let's show
this essentially do the same thing oh
except I put plus equals x so that it's
doubling each time as you can see that
works
now there is some shortcuts shorthands
you can capture all local variables with
the equals sign this will capture both
doubles and if there was more stuff it
would capture it as well
there it is it does indeed capture them
but what if you want to capture them all
as a reference that one we just did was
by copy this one is how you do it by
reference and ampersand
I've took them both by reference I'm
going to be modifying them both and then
spitting out the results a total of
three times
there it is it seems to work it's
doubling you did it three times
and now here is a semi real-world
example of using the lambda with a class
we're making this class called thing
while we are including that stream
because we're going to do a example of
outputting to a file we're using this
class thing which has an operation
within it called save and this writes
out its data to a file
so what we have here
is this thing with a constructor
if you pass nothing to the constructor
it sets data to zero if you pass an
integer to the constructor it sets the
data to that and then it has this public
function to save which needs a reference
doing it to a stream and output stream
and what it does here is it just help
puts the data to the output stream
followed by a new line so how do we use
this in practice and with a lambda well
say for example you have a list of thing
pointers so we've made three of these
one called zero which is going to be the
value zero I'll call one which is gonna
be the value one one called forty two
which is called gonna be the value 42
using these constructors and then we're
saving all these pointers to these three
objects to a list
so we make a an out file and then we use
our for each function to go through that
list of pointers and
use this function every time so the way
you do that is you need to pass those
the outfile stream downstream by
reference or capture it rather by
reference and every iteration of this
loop it's going to pass in the current
pointers it's on in that pointer is
going to call save and use the reference
to the app file
so what happens if we run this we should
in theory make a file that's zero one
forty two if it works
so let's do a quick cat to look at our
outfile
thing output RTF
there it is 0-1 42 you just approve it
wasn't already there I'm gonna go ahead
and remove it and then run this again
and then we'll look at it again
so that's an example of how you can use
it to cull function of that class save
you many lines of code
and now we're getting close to the end
here you can if you're using a lambda
within a class definition somewhere you
can use the of this keyword to get a
reference to that class that's how you
capture the members of a class you would
think that you type in their names but
you don't instead you just need this so
for example here I will walk through
this code and explain what it does we
see two different constructors one that
initializes to zero if he passes nothing
or one that initializes this criterion
to whatever you pass in whatever number
an integer put in there and it has a
function here that is supposed to get a
count of how many in this list are
higher than the criteria number then we
have a function to add things to the end
list since the end list is private and
as you can see here let's get how many
higher than criteria uses a for each
that increases the count and it uses a
lambda function here as it goes through
that int list so it takes in this
instead of all the variables it needs
which is M criteria and they I am count
static it uses this and it takes into
about UI which was coming from the synth
list and it says keep that I'm skipping
over if I is greater than the criteria
then increase the count then when it's
all done doing that it returns the count
how many were higher than that criteria
in here we just have a main that runs it
it makes a version of this class that
has a criteria of five and then we're
just pushing eight variables to the list
each of them is I plus three so it'll go
for two what is that 12 four to 12 or
maybe it'll be four to eleven yes
four to eleven so we should get that six
are higher
when we run this that would be the
expected result so what we're running it
right there and it's gonna do that whole
thing using its for each with a lambda
so let's go ahead it is saved I'm gonna
type make run
you should get our results oh I counted
wrong there are five higher than five so
this would be four five six seven eight
nine
ten
11:36
I must be heaven off by one error Oh
anyways it does seem to work and go
through that I could probably make it a
little simpler and say zero and we
should get a steady eight
that's here yes here we go
this would initialize with the default
one which will set it to zero
oh and it says eight or higher than five
because I have manually typed in five
year so that's why I said that but as
expected there are eight higher than
zero and that's it
the references I mainly use to figure
all this stuff out was the en CPP
reference com
or you can look up more details about
any of these functions used in here this
is all the standard library and the
handout that I showed you at the
beginning of the video video these links
will be down below as well as the repo
with all the code I hope you have a good
day and that you learn more about
lambdas don't forget to like if this
video helped you out and consider
subscribing if you want to see more
various stuff about code and tech my
personal specialty is C++ but I might do
other tutorials too thanks for watching
keep coding and have a good day